sie sind der flammenhölle von moria
entkommen sie haben wirklich alles
verloren müssen auf der straße schlafen
auf parkplätzen manche haben nicht mal
eine decke um sich nachts zuzudecken und
schlafen zu können was ihnen bleibt ist
wirklich nur auf hilfe zu warten
immerhin mittlerweile ist das deutsche
thw aufgebrochen um den menschen auf
lesbos zu helfen
für manche inselbewohner eine unhaltbare
situation
sie wollen keine lager mehr und gehen
auf die barrikaden
das flüchtlingslager moria ist
abgebrannt
unglaubliches leid für die bewohner
außerhalb des abgebrannten camps wütende
bürger der 80.000 einwohner insel lesbos
sie errichten barrikaden damit das camp
für die 13.000 flüchtlinge nicht wieder
aufgebaut werden kann
die flüchtlinge seien weg was die bürger
offenbar nicht wissen nach bild
informationen soll das lager ganz
woanders wieder errichtet werden etwa
zehn frauen und männer haben sich in den
schatten hinter dem bulldozer auf
plastikstühle gesetzt
eigentlich wollen sie nicht mit
journalisten reden aber dann öffnet sich
einer doch ein wenig duschen singh vor
sich
wer vorher müssen noch vorher
repro masao yoshida tomorrow wir haben
dienst mitarbeiter werden jetzt von
lokalen medien zitiert
angeblich soll der brand von jungen
männern gelegt worden sein deren
asylanträge abgelehnt worden waren da
ganz klare reaktion von einem
inselbewohner sie sehen jetzt meinen
kollegen til biermann er steht auf
lesbos und till jetzt ist ja gerade ein
tränengaseinsatz passiert kannst du uns
sagen was bei dir vor ort gerade
passiert gehen dass einsatz war vor
circa einer stunde eines geschlossenen
lidls promatis mehr
es war ein kleinerer einsatz es gab dann
ein paar schlimme bild aber das war auch
ziemlich schnell abgeschlossen was genau
dahintersteckt warum jetzt diese tränen
glas tränengas granaten geworfen wurde
ist noch nicht offenbar die lage
eskaliert wirklich auf lesbos du hast ja
mit verschiedenen menschen gesprochen
mit flüchtlingen mit einwohnern
was kannst du uns dazu sagen wie
reagieren die menschen aktuell
tatsächlich ist es so dass alle
eigentlich dagegen sind dass die das
hier auf lesbos so weitergeht und zwar
die flüchtlinge die geweckt wollen
die die einwohner und auch die
hilfsorganisation so wie ich das
verstanden habe
diese lage hier unhaltbar ist das lager
moria war ursprünglich für 3000 menschen
konzipiert und dabei zeitweise 20.000
und diese insel hat 80.000 einwohnern
aus 80.000 120.000 flüchtlinge dazu das
ist sehr viel
und wenn man dann mit den einheimischen
spricht es ist schon so dass die meisten
sagen die flüchtlinge wollen weg wir
wollen sie auch hier nicht mehr haben
europa soll sie aufnehmen
und ich sprach auch mit einem polizisten
in der altstadt am hafen der sagte mir
das problem ist
aber sobald man hieraus nicht 500
flüchtlinge abgeholt werden so wie das
am 30 august 2009 10 kam am 31 august
1500 neue ausstattung zeit dazu das
heißt
laut diesen polizisten sind die schleppe
auch sehr gut informiert wie die lage
hier aussieht
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren